okay good afternoon who knows who said
this so I felt it was appropriate no you
got to go only because I told you well
that's good I felt it was appropriate
that that should be extra credit on your
next exam who thinks that's fair
of course it's phase just go to Google
and you look it up alright so this is
this is actually said by satchel page
and he was of course referring to
something else but it's really the case
of what happens when a cell was invaded
by a virus cells have all these
wonderful intrinsic mechanisms that they
used to fight off various bacteria and
fungi and viruses and yet all of these
organisms strive there really work hard
at it to get beyond those defenses and
that's what we're going to talk about
today in a lot of contexts covering a
lot of ground and some things that you
know and hopefully a few things that you
don't know so that there's some new
material here
so the question of course is what does
one do to the other and the host as we
have said is there in principle to avoid
being infected after all infection is
not something that you really want on
the other hand sometimes there are
benefits from being infected believe it
or not but the viruses and other
organisms really want to get through
that and their main objective is to
replicate so it's a battle whoops of
evolutionary strategies that have
evolved between hosts and various
organisms as you look from the most
primitive organisms like worms all the
way up to humans if we are the most
evolved we find that there are different
ways of dealing with pathogens and so we
have primitive innate immune responses
and some of the very lower organisms and
we carry these through from Drosophila
the man in terms of the toll-like
receptors the doctor I can yellow told
you about and we have adaptive cell
responses to
infection and these include both B cells
that make antibodies form your humoral
immune system and T cells which directly
target infected cells process antigens
release cytokines and control much of
what goes on in terms of the adaptive
response for the virus the goal is to
survive to reproduce and then just to
get the hell out of there
and go find somebody else to infect all
right so that's where we are how do you
do this well a great way of doing it is
to overwhelm the host but as it turns
out that's not easy and for the most
part it's only infections infections
only occur relatively low multiplicities
of infection so you don't get infected
with thousands and millions of particles
unless somebody sneezes directly on you
viruses seek to enter parentally and
that's any other way than the gut and
the reason for that is the guts really a
nasty place to be you've got to go
through the stomach you've got to go
through a very acidic environment you go
into the small intestine and it's full
of other microorganisms it's full of
some wonderful immune cells that
recognize pathogens and take things out
it's coated with mucus and so it's a
tough way to start it's much easier to
enter through the bloodstream through
the lungs and the first thing that these
viruses want to do is to disarm the host
well you saw this slide two days ago two
lectures ago recently
and what I want to emphasize is the
course of virus growth during an acute
infection and how the host plays a role
in this so we have the virus entering
the host and that's the establishment of
infection getting in finding a cell in
which you can replicate that immediately
triggers all of the native immune system
all of those little molecules that are
both extrinsic sitting on the outside of
the cell and intrinsic sitting inside
the cells when they respond and they get
cells to produce various cytokines and
they cause mobilization of macrophages
and they eat up all the virus and you
survive but not always and sometimes
what happens is the virus continues to
replicate and sometimes it replicates in
these cells that are attacking infected
cells so we get the induction of the
adaptive response and the adaptive
immune response is a two component
system both cellular and humoral with
the humoral system actually taking quite
a long time and in fact you don't
usually see the adaptive response in
terms of the outcome until symptoms have
developed so all this while you're not
sick but you're going to be and the
question then becomes when do you treat
a viral infection and the answer is of
course some ways in this period before
things go crazy anyways we have this
adaptive response and that usually goes
towards clearing the virus except in
some exceptional cases and we'll talk
about those next week or maybe it's the
week after and then you're left with
memory cells and the memory cells are
there to recapitulate whatever happened
the first time but to respond more
rapidly so how does the virus invade all
of these different components of the
immune system and when I talk about
immunity now I'm not talking just about
b-cells and t-cells I'll be talking
about some of the intrinsic molecules
and the pathways that are
elaborated in response to infection well
you want to disarm the innate immune
system one of the choice ways that
viruses have evolved to deal with
evasion is to regulate major
histocompatibility complex molecules and
these MHC molecules are responsible for
antigen presentation and they come in a
couple of flavors MHC 1 and MHC 2 and
then they these activities occur in
different cell types the other thing
that viruses can do is interfere with
cytotoxic T cells and with natural
killer cells and they find ways to
regulate these cells fool essentially
because they're much smarter than the
cells are and effectively what happens
is these cells don't do their job they
don't lyse infected cells they can alter
antigen presentation in any number of
ways and we'll talk about that in a
great more detail towards the end of the
lecture and finally they can go and hide
after all if somebody's running after
you and they're bigger than you you want
to go and hide right it's a way to get
out of it and we'll talk about that
later again so persistence and latency
is a great way for viruses to go away
and come back and annoy you at some
later date so what are the host defenses
the immune system and it recognizes
signals signals that are present on
virus molecules viral antigens that are
presented to the system by macrophages
by dendritic cells by various t-cells
and its purpose is to not just recognize
the signal but to amplify the cell more
is better more allows for a response
okay and when you have an amplified
signal you have the opportunity to
control the invader in one way shape or
form the innate immune system
I say responds to everything well it
doesn't really respond to
everything but the response a very many
components of viruses and dr. Rajan
yellow has introduced these to you I
talked when I talked about DNA
replication and transcription I talked
about nuclear molecules that form
components within the nucleus and these
introdu clea modular Tory molecules are
responsible for changing the ability of
viruses to establish infection and some
of them turn out to be is G's so they're
interferon stimulated teams and some of
them will actually interfere will
actually induce interferon in a
different way we have the interference
that induce an antiviral state we have
the protein kinase R which
phosphorylates CIF to alpha and stops
translation thereby abrogating virus
infection our bodies are full of
complement and when complement is
activated in the presence of
immunoglobulin it'll punch holes in
membranes kill cells that are infected
as I said before we have the natural
killers and the cytotoxic t-lymphocytes
and we have macrophages and neutrophils
so there's a whole armamentarium of
different weapons that the body presents
to anything that invades and it's an
obstacle course and you've got to get
through it and pathogens are very good
at it the adaptive immune response is a
member response that is you have a
response and that remains with you
hopefully for your whole life it's
activated in response to the innate
immune response so the primary response
the innate immune response results in
the release of cytokines that stimulate
cells it gets them activated it lets
them see molecules it draws cells to the
site of infection this resulted in
several expansions b-cells and t-cells
and for this these two events to occur
requires th1 and th2 cells and these
cells T lymphocytes all cd4 positive
cells release certain cytokines that
activate B cells and
he sells to expand and we also have the
generation of the cytotoxic T cells and
antibody production so we have the
humoral the arm the humeral arm of
response and the cellular R we also have
just regular old inflammatory responses
those reddened areas except at
co-occurring side and that occurs in
response to necrosis cell death virus
gets in replicates it kills a cell in
which it's replicating as a result of
that frequently what you do is you
release cytokines encima chemokines and
if you don't release them you draw cells
that see these new foreign antigens on
the surface to the infected site and
they will release them and their purpose
is to recruit neutrophils and
macrophages to the site of damage and
they are essentially cells that are
garbage cancer and they'll eat anything
that's in their pathway and hopefully
that results in destruction of the cell
and the virus attendant sometimes
however the results an infection of the
neutrophil and the macrophage because
the virus has gone far enough long it's
intact it gets an easy entry into the
cell and it has an opportunity to
replicate as I said the cytokines are
the primary output of the innate immune
response and depending upon which toll
receptor is tickled you get a different
family of cytokines induced it's a great
response because it's rapid as soon as
something hits begins to replicate
leaves a trail or a trace these guys are
made they control inflammation although
too much of them can start inflammation
so you've heard of cytokine storms
perhaps which are hugely over synthesis
of cytokines which generally meet to
organ failure and death cytokines induce
the antiviral state and interferons are
the main culprit in that and they
regulate the immune system so what does
the virus do virus is smart it makes
fire codes
and these guys for all the world look
like feel like smell like in fact act
like normal chemokines and these
mimetics are faithful enough so that
they bind to the appropriate receptor
and sequester those receptors but they
don't activate them so they fit but not
quite right and then we have viral
receptors and these are also elaborated
by a variety of viruses and these are
soluble cytokine receptors so you've got
an infected cell you've got an infected
organ the virus elaborates this receptor
it goes out into the cytoplasm it
captures all the raging cytokines
sequester's them and they don't get a
chance to do what they want to do so you
abrogate initiation of the response so
what we can do is we can sabotage both
innate and adaptive defense without
affecting growth in cell culture because
most of these molecules are not made in
cell culture the interferons are but
most of the receptors and T cells on
whatever are not present so viruses will
replicate in cell culture because they
can get through these responses now
interferon this comes in a variety of
flavors for that we know about maybe
more and the virus has to counter the
effects of interferon and the reason is
pretty simple without interferon the
host has a reduced ability to contain
viral infections so infections spread
rapidly you lose that rapidly acting arm
of the innate immune system viruses do
it in a variety of ways turns out that
we have viruses that make
double-stranded RNA binding proteins so
the NS one protein from influenza the
e3h protein from pops viruses us 11 from
herpes simplex virus these are proteins
that actually bind double-stranded RNA
and so it's not seen by the rig I sub
signalling system
add no virus elaborates a very small
double-stranded RNA that's made in
enormous amounts and that
double-stranded RNA acts as a decoy that
binds protein kinase r when you bind it
you take it out of out of the pathway
for inhibiting translation so here we
have a list don't memorize it okay and
the idea here is just to show you the
wide variety of ways in which viruses
make products that attack various arms
of the interferon response so they can
inhibit interferon synthesis and we do
it in a couple of ways we can regulate
double-stranded RNA production we can
block host protein synthesis that's a
rather brutal way to do that well we
have homologues that inhibit production
of interferons such as il-10 by the
epstein-barr virus we also have
interferon receptor decoys again soaking
up the soluble chemokine preventing it
from doing what it should do you can
inhibit signaling of interferon either
by decreasing the amount of stat that's
present in that cellular membrane at the
jak-stat receptors you can actually
interfere with phosphorylation of stats
you can block proteins with which they
interact and that prevents the signaling
pathway and then you can block the
function of interferon induced proteins
and what we know is that there are
hundreds of these what we don't know is
what most of them do so that's an open
question in terms of what else there is
to look at but we have things such as a
PK or decoy we have molecules that bind
double-stranded RNA and PKA R we have
molecules that block the action of
specific is G's and all of these are
different ways that viruses choose or
have adapted or have evolved to abrogate
the interferon response now some of the
regulators of is G's again we come back
to these nuclear domain ten
that a composed of host proteins and
these host proteins have a role in
repressing virus replication and they
form the innate nuclear defense so not
only do we have site of not only do we
have proteins at the cell surface and
proteins in the cytoplasm but we have
proteins in the nucleus whose purpose is
to effectively prevent the virus from
replicating and this results in sort of
an epigenetic regulation of virus
replication it's not direct what it's
doing is taking away something it's
taking away a replication compartment
not allowing the virus to establish
itself and the promyelocytic leukemia
protein PML is an important and d-10
constituent and that happens to be
degraded by some viral proteins and in
particular herpes simplex virus and it's
very close relative varicella-zoster
virus and they're going to get this
right away okay
okay both replicate in the nucleus both
established replication compartments at
a part of nd tens but in one case they
attack PML and the other case they don't
so here's a picture of that here's the
cell infected with herpes simplex virus
the red represents a protein called IC
p0 and here's a cell infected with
varicella-zoster virus and the red
represents or 61p and these proteins are
very very similar they're awful logs and
yet the simplex virus protein results in
the complete loss of PML so look at this
here's our IC p0 here's our no p ml and
here the cell that's expressing both so
here's an uninfected cell and here's an
infected zone we don't see the little
green dots however it's different for
varicella-zoster here's the pathologist
protein 61 p and you'll see that p ml
persists in these cells so viruses that
have evolutionarily conserved proteins
can have different functions another way
in which the host seeks to abort virus
infection is to regulate translation and
viruses again seek to alter that fate
and they want to modify the host to fade
the synthesis of their own proteins so
that their own messenger rna's are being
used we've heard about cap independent
translation we've heard about irises and
there are yet other ways in which
viruses attack this innate system and
that's to change the way in which
protein synthesis occurs in which
various mRNAs are seen so interferon
accomplishes the antiviral state it
induces PKR and other if to alpha
tenacious and remember that those are
important proteins for initiation of
translation so when you do that you
inhibit translation and what are the
consequences for virus replication well
a virus that's in a cell that can't
produce proteins
is not going to survive forever
messenger rna's have some sort of a
finite half-life the genomes are present
either in the cytoplasm of the nucleus
then can persist only for a certain
period of time unless they can go latent
and eventually under those conditions
the cell will win out
so PKR is activated by binding
double-stranded RNA when that happens in
order phosphorylates itself at a serine
51 i residue and once that occurs it's
able the activated p KR is able to
phosphorylate EF e i f out to alpha when
phosphorylated it forms a very tight
ternary complex with gdp-bound CIF 2
beta and that blocks recycling of the
initiation complex and translation is
arrested but viruses have evolved ways
to thwart these anti virus defenses and
here are a couple of examples so for
example there's a protein that's
elaborated by herpes simplex virus
called u.s. 11 and this protein actually
binds to PK r so prevents it from doing
what it should do which is
phosphorylated to target it also
prevents it from being activated the ID
no virus v a RNAs that I told you about
briefly before inhibit by binding
tightly to PK r and that's a double
stranded DNA decoy there are hundreds of
thousands of these molecules inside of
an infected cell so it's a very
efficient way of blocking the host
response and then a protein from human
papilloma virus called e6 which is an
important program protein in regulating
papilloma virus replication and a very
bizarre little protein made in herpes
simplex virus infected cells gamma
because it's a very late gene in 34.5
because obviously was between 34 and 35
d phosphorylate AI F 2 alpha and one of
them we know the mechanism that's 34.5
interacts with protein phosphatase 1 and
redirects it to if to alpha and that's
all pretty much summarized on this next
slide you can see that in the normal
course of activation of the if2 alpha
you have the gdp-bound form it interacts
with E I F to be and then it goes
through this cycle interacting with tRNA
and starting the initiation complex us
11 our protein had no virus varn a's
prevent activation these guys prevent
the movement of these molecules into a
functionally I F to be complex by
phosphorylating CIF 2 alpha when you
phosphorylate this guy excuse me I'm
sorry this is the natural pathway of PKR
in and it will phosphorylate this guy in
response to virus infection and now
you've get a ternary complex which
really is extremely stable so it can't
recycle what happens with these guys is
they prevent the phosphorylation or they
actually have the phosphate removed
after induction of another protein so
that you don't form this complex and
translation continuous how do you
modulate interferon there are lots of
ways of doing it
one is you can inhibit interferon
synthesis and if you're effectively
blocking translation you're inhibiting
the synthesis of interferon and just
about everything else you can synthesize
a decoy or bring a decoy in that will
sequester interferon so that it doesn't
get out of the cell or when it comes and
it is out of the cell it doesn't enter
another cell you can inhibit interferon
signalling using these viral receptors
or you can block the function of
interferon stimulated genes such as PK
or another method that the cell uses or
the host uses to escape infection leads
to cell death and that's a puto psious
so a virus comes into a cell and the
cell sees the virus and it sees this is
not a good thing and it wants to respond
and what it does is it sacrifices itself
and it dies but it dies in a very
characteristic way and the hosts escape
mechanism that leads to cell death
results in inflammation by cysteine
protease is known as caspases you'll
also see induction of cytokines in
response to what's elaborated by the
infected cell it's dying and the
infected cells release proteins that are
subsequently presented by MHC 2 so when
those proteins are gobbled up by
lymphocytes in the cell or macrophages
they are then degraded into linear
epitopes and presented on the surface of
cells by MHC 2 and finally it results in
activation of cytotoxic t-cells so this
sacrifice this cell dying helps to save
the organ or or the organism by
activating the immune response the host
controls induction and suppression and
it does it through a family of moloch
molecules known as either BIA bcl-2 or
Beck's and dad the bcl-2 family members
are anti a photonic so it's a normal
state of the cell not to kill itself
it's a good way to be all right
and the bcl-2 family members brought
block translocation of pro-apoptotic
molecules to the mitochondria and when
these pro ape attack molecules get to
the mitochondria or to the endoplasmic
reticulum they result in the release of
proteins and calcium molecules that
perturb the cells and cause massive
chaos inside the cell Backson bad or
pro-apoptotic molecules in fact they
form an oligomers one backs one bad and
there are other members of these
families that can be part of this party
and when they get together they'll cause
an induction of a caspase cascade and
the release of cytochrome C from the
mitochondria
so this is the intrinsic depth receptor
pathway and here on the top we have our
bcl-2 members here our backs and back
back
one of those should be bad but here it
is and there are other component members
and when these two guys are together
they will lodge into the membranes of
Hydra mitochondria or ER and release
molecules if you have enough bcl-2 or
one of its homologs they will replace or
prevent the organization and you don't
see release of these molecules release
of these molecules including cytochrome
c caspase-9 and AP f1 causes the
formation of something called an Apopka
soma which is a large structure inside
of a cell which is composed of these
proteins that oligomers and they have
essentially activate effector caspases
that leave to lead to a pitocin
there's also an extrinsic pathway and
here you see activation of caspases as a
result of ligands very specific ligands
such as 2 min across this factor fast
hypo 2d trail interacting with receptors
on cell surfaces that release caspases
into the cytoplasm so you can do it from
the inside of the cell and you can do it
from the outside of the cell the effect
is the same the cell apoptosis
what are some the characteristics of a
proposal cell organelles are dismantled
they really come apart the entire cell
dissolves musicals form and membranes on
the outside the cell actually begin to
bleb so you look like sort of like the
Pillsbury Doughboy there are lots of
little blob that are on the surface of
the cell DNA is cleaved so it's an event
that transcends not just the cytoplasm
also goes into the nucleus what's that
it's telling you is that end in new
cases are released and the DNA the
chromosome is being destroyed and
strange molecules are placed on the cell
surface
and those happen to be markers crepey
ptosis so if you look at it this is what
happens the normal cell in response to
some sort of signal begins to a potosi
cell architecture changes it begins to
release these vacuoles these eight
patata bodies the nucleus goes to hell
chromosomes condense they get chewed up
by editing nucleases and lo and behold
the macrophage comes along and cleans up
the mess but in doing so the macrophage
has now been signaled that something bad
is going on in this cell and what's bad
is the virus infection has happened now
if you blockade the ptosis you allow the
virus to finish its infectious cycle so
what you have is a battle between the
virus and the host who can win who can
get there first who can do their
business before the other one so let's
just take a quick look at some of the
characteristics of a pre ptosis and
these are cells that are infected with a
mutant of herpes simplex virus and the
reason for that is that the wild type
virus suppresses ap ptosis but when you
delete the gene that's involved in
suppressing a photo --ss you see that
even very early after infection strange
structures form on the surface of cells
and these are the blebs that are
characteristic of a proto psious and if
you look inside the cell you'll see all
of these vacuoles that aligning the
cytoplasm so membrane blebbing and a
pathetic body formation these vesicles
that get shoved off and getting eaten up
by the macrophages are part and parcel
of hypnosis
another thing that occurs during a photo
sis is that certain proteins are cleaved
and cleavage of these proteins results
in a proptosis inducing signals among
those proteins are something called Park
or poly adp-ribose polymerase DNA
fragmentation factor and caspase-3
and once again we're going to compare
what happens in a wild-type cell with
what happens in a mutant cell and you
can see this
product 85 accumulates in mutant cells
but not until very late times after
infection and wild-type cells so the
wild-type cell prevents the cleavage of
that guy and this guy and caspase-3
where's the mutant which doesn't have
the anti a product activity allows
cleavage of park allows cleavage of DNA
fragmentation factor and allows cleavage
of caspase-3 and as a result of that the
cell like mitosis that's not good for
the virus the virus suffers here we see
a picture of the same kind of events
occurring with DNA fragmentation this is
a hog roast gel in which DNA is loaded
at the top right over here and then it's
electrophoresis II that the size of the
DNA and the wild-type infected cells is
different from what's present in a
mutant cells in fact there are let
little adders that look how many even
know what nucleosomes are everybody
please raise your hand ok so that looked
like nucleosome ladders very discreet
cuts that occur in the DNA and that's
because the DNA is being fragmented so
why block a proptosis well after
infection cells are activated in
response to the virus and what you do is
you frequently activate quiescent cell
machinery at the wrong time in the cell
cycle so when we talked about DNA
replication we talked about the fact
that DNA viruses frequently used
something from the host but not all host
cells are in the process of DNA
replication as a result of that they
induce these proteins they induce these
cycles and they activate quiescent cell
machinery when things are made at the
wrong time checkpoint control signals
respond checkpoints are normal cell
constituents that are there to control
how a cell moves through its replication
cycle the virus responds to complete
replication and why because if you fail
you get decreased yields
now if you a pat o s-- you're going to
release virus antigens so you want to
inhibit the release of virus antigens so
that the virus can effectively hide from
the cells from the host and it does that
by eliminating T cell activation and by
evading the immune response all those
are good for the virus bad for you
here's a simple slide which diagrams
about a hundred different virus proteins
that are involved in attacking every
single point in the processes of a Patou
--ss and what you should take from this
is that it's a complicated process I
made all the letters really small so you
can't read any of them but what you want
to think about is the fact that a photo
Siskin be blocked from the cell surface
at the cell surface through the
signalling components by blocking or by
scavenging free radicals which are also
induces of a plateau --ss by inhibiting
the release of caspases from
mitochondrial cytochrome C by inhibiting
transcription of is G's and other
factors other proteins that are involved
in starting a pitocin mechanism so
evolution selects viruses make the
minimal number of proteins that they
need to get where they are and they
succeed sometimes so here are a couple
of examples of from that previous slide
and it's interesting to note that a
non-coding RNA from human
cytomegalovirus can bind a protein in
the mitochondria just like va RNA binds
PKR and that protein normally triggers
ap ptosis but if it's bound by this RNA
it's not free to do that
adenovirus makes an early protein called
e 1b and that binds backs when you bind
backs you take it out of its pro
apoptotic pathway and that prevents
caspase activation that's the intrinsic
pathway
aDNA makes another protein III which
blocks the
receptor fasts and so you no longer can
induce a pitocin and that works
extrinsic way so there are many
different ways in which you can get
around the problem now another protein
that cells make and is interesting in
its own right is a protein called April
Beck April Beck was discovered about ten
years ago and it's a protein family
whose sole purpose
well maybe not sole purpose as function
is to edit RNA and it's an interferon
induced protein and what it does is it
deaminate site Adeem to your dean you're
delayed actually and that's an intrinsic
antiviral and it's able to block the
replication of HIV hepatitis B virus and
measles virus so these guys is you will
recognize from what dr. Ratton yellow
has told you is replicate in very
different ways yet they're all
effectively inhibited by a BEC
interestingly this protein is
incorporated into HIV virus particles so
if the protein is in the virus particle
is the host a step ahead the HIV
epidemic would tell you that the host is
not a step ahead okay and in fact what
the virus does is it makes another
protein called Neph which interferes
with a BEC so how does a paper Beck
inhibit HIV replication what it does I
told you was an RNA direct molecule but
it also works on single-stranded DNA and
what does is it attacks C's in minus
strand DNA and the ammonites them this
CD you transition results in the change
from GC base pairs to a T base pairs and
if you have a codon such as one for
tryptophane and you change those GC
pairs to ET you become a stop codon so
you make lots of premature proteins you
containing DNA as it turns out is also
attacked by an enzyme in cells called
uracil DNA gleich
today's and that Cleaves a basic cites
and I'm sorry generates a basic site so
it removes the base those are recognized
by in their nucleases and the DNA is
clear so that first product of reverse
transcription is taken out of the loop
so how does HIV survive a per BEC it
survives because of this protein if I
told you it was Neff but it's live which
is incorporated also in the very on and
viv interacts in a species specific
manner to bind a prevent and targeted to
the protein proteosome the protein in
the proteosome the protein gets chewed
up now the species specificity is an
interesting problem and if you
substitute human with murine then this
doesn't work because it doesn't
recognize that paper Beck so the virus
goes on and survives in that case now
for immune modulation one of the first
responses after the innate immune
response is that of dendritic cells and
dendritic cells come to scoop up the
mess and clean things up and present
antigens and recognize sites of
inflammation and they're very often
compromised by a virus infection and
once you compromise those the ones that
start the immune response then what you
get effectively is suppression of the
immune response and it can occur as a
result of interference with recruitment
so you don't bring dendritic cells to
the site of infection
there's signals that are required to get
them there or lost impairment of antigen
uptake so they don't take up the
proteins or even processing of these
proteins elaborated by the virus if you
don't process the proteins that are
taken up you don't process the virus
fragments then you don't present
anything to the immune system
and then things just remain hidden you
can interfere with maturation of
dendritic cells in order for them to
an antigen they have to mature you can
interfere with their ability to migrate
to lymphoid tissue with a percent
antigen to various T cells and you can
interfere with the failure with their
ability to activate T cells so these
excuse me are all different ways in
which dendritic cells can be compromised
as a result of elaboration of various
virus proteins natural killer cells T
cells effectively recognize and survey
the body looking for target cells that
are elaborating a certain molecules
natural killer cells have no antigen
receptors but they have two other
receptors there's an inhibitory receptor
and that inhibitory receptor recognizes
cells that produce MHC 1 and whose MHC
one is loaded with peptide so those are
antigen producing cells there's another
receptor on the NK cell and that's the
activating receptor and that recognizes
a protein on the surface of a target
cell in the absence of this or in some
how when this is interfered with the
inhibitory receptor is much stronger
than the activating receptor and that's
probably a good thing you don't want to
activate NK cells all the time so
properties of NK cells they have no
antigen receptors per se they secrete
cytokines again so you see cytokines
over and over again in every aspect of
the immune response they kill cells that
lack MHC one on the surface by
recognizing missing self if it ain't
there it's dead it's a target and it's
not there for certain reasons antibody
dependent cellular cytotoxicity involves
NK cells binding to immunoglobulin coded
cells and when they see that it results
in the release of preference and
granzymes into the target cell and that
triggers a pitocin
now how does a virus modulate NK cells
well some viruses actually Express MHC
one homologues so they look just like
what they should look like on the cell
surface and that activates the
inhibitory receptor it keeps them from
triggering the NK cell they regulate MHC
they regulate its transcription and in
some cases its translation and in some
cases where it goes inside the cell in
an incredible dance of molecules that
occurs throughout the infected cell and
in normal cells they can release virus
encoded cytokine binding proteins back
to virus scepters and they can block
engagement of the activating receptor
they can also be antagonists of the
activating receptor keep everything down
on the form don't let the surfs have an
uprising get qaddafi before he gets to
benghazi infection of NK cells can lead
to disruption of function or to cell
death so the virus gets into the NK cell
can kill the cell so here's a schematic
of everything that I've just illustrated
to you the viruses that have MHC class 1
homologues are seen by the NK cell and
they activate the inhibitory receptor
nothing happens sometimes the viruses
reduce the synthesis of MHC but allow
the synthesis of another HLA like
molecule that sort of mimics MHC so MHC
is gone but this guy looks a lot like it
enough like it so that it engages the
inhibitory receptor and prevents the NK
cell from being activated there are
active there are activating receptor
antagonists which are made by infected
cells which bind to the activating
receptor and prevent it from activating
the NK cell there are viral viral
receptors which are elaborated by these
cells which can bind to cytokines or
chemokines and prevent stimulation of
the NK cell and then there are cytokines
and chemokines that act as agonists to
bind to cytokine receptors and prevent
that activity and finally you have the
ability sometimes of the virus to
actually be taken up by the inhibitory
receptor and get into the cell in fact
it kill it and therefore lower the
response here are a couple of clever
ways in which virus proteins effectively
abrogate the NK response hepatitis C
makes an envelope protein so it's on the
surface of the virus e - that binds to
the activating receptor cdat one on NK
cells and it blocks activation therefore
they don't recognize infected cells HIV
makes a small protein called Neph and
that affects cell surface expression of
some MHC molecules but not the HLA e
molecule the cell is still protected
poxviruses expressed proteins that bind
il-12 and that inhibits interferon gamma
production by NK cells NK cells are the
primary producers of interferon gamma so
you have different ways of affecting
what the NK cell can do when it sees its
target on to adaptive immunity and the
responses that are affected both at the
humoral level and the cell mediated
level so cell mediated immunity immunity
T cell condition is mediated by membrane
bound antigen on b-cells and/or the t
cell receptor it occurs in response to
antigen that's presented by MHC 1 on all
cells or by MHC 2 on macrophages or
dendritic cells so we know that T helper
and cytolytic T cells cd4 and cd8 cells
have these T cell receptors on
recognize different molecules and that
the B cells have antibody receptors on
them and that all these guys are binding
antigens the B cells as linear epitopes
bigger chunks the T cells has peptides
that are presented in the context of MHC
and the one thing that's in common
between all these different mechanisms
is that binding releases cytokines and
that results in stimulation of cell
division clonal expansion more guys to
fight the battle it's important to note
that cd4 th cells differentiate into
both th1 and th2 cells and that just
means they elaborate different cytokines
and they effectively control the
propagation either of the humoral
response or the cd8 response th1 cells
release interleukin 1 and interferon
gamma and th2 cells release aisle 4 6
and 10 and they promote the antibody
response now what are the effects of
stimulating cell division so you have an
antigen you see it and the cell responds
its response by dividing by
proliferating you get clonal expansion
as I said before increases the number of
cell responders t-cells kill cells
bearing foreign peptide of protein cd4
positive T helpers recognize MHC class 2
molecules and peptides that are bound by
them the linear reputable cd8 T cells
recognize MHC 1 bound peptides more 9 or
11 amino acid peptides so I can't
remember and in response to cytokines
from th 1 cells cd8 cells become mature
cytotoxic T cells so they go out they
search and they kill in response to the
cytokines from the th two cells
cd4 guys B cells synthesize an antibody
and they become a plasma cell again
you're expanding a number of cells that
can produce antibody increase the
humoral response and you have people
to fight the infection the b-cell can
also become a memory cell setting in
your body for 40 or 50 years waiting to
be infected again or in some cases a
little bit more often and respond with a
rapid humoral response what do these
cells look like they look just like this
okay the major the major difference
between cd4 and cd8 cells is the
engagement of the t-cell receptor on
these cells they share other membrane
proteins and these proteins are there to
recognize partners on target cells and
the cd4 cell recognizes peptide as
presented by MHC 2 and the cd8 cell
recognizes peptide as presented by MHC 1
so you have 2 signal systems you have
these MHC molecules and their accessory
molecules and their ligands and when
these things are engaged what they do is
they lead to t-cell activation so you
lead to clonal expansion you lead to
proliferation of cells you recruit the
army everybody gets drafted
just to recapitulate for you here's our
vertebrate body we have humoral response
arm and the cell mediated response arm
from the bone marrow we have naive
t-cells which can be educated in the
thymus to become cd4 or cd8 cells to
help her or CTL precursors the cd8 arm
recognizes antigen as presented by MHC 1
cd4 by MHC 2 when the cd4 cell is
activated it can either release th1
cytokines of it because of th one cell
that stimulates maturation of CTL and
gets them to their point where they can
recognize infected cells and if their th
- and they're releasing th2 cytokines it
stimulates B cells to become plasma
cells and secrete antibody so those are
receptive molecules and what they do is
they engage they well they engage
various molecules that allow them to be
differentiated into so cells are first
cd8 cd4 positive their double positives
before they go into the thymus and then
they get selected and on the basis of
that these molecules allow them or
change the ability of these cells to
produce various cytokines so cd4 cells
for example are the hosts for HIV not
cd8 and cd4 is one of the molecules
that's part of the HIV receptor complex
so what you're essentially doing is
you're getting out cells that have
different functions derived from the
same cell type but because of species
let's call it speciation I don't know
what else to call it or maturation in
the thymus they become like the cd4
positive or cd8 and those receptors on
the surface of the cell cd8 and cd4 are
seen by various molecules on activated
cells and provide a variety of functions
so how does the virus attack the t-cell
response different viruses do it in
different ways epstein-barr virus or
herpes virus that all of you have or if
you don't you will encodes an il-10
homolog that suppresses the th1 response
there's precedent to suppress the th1
response you spare infected b-cells
turns out ksatriya more recently
discovered herpes virus responsible for
Kaposi sarcoma elaborates a horde of
viral kinds it's as though it went into
the host it picked up five six seven
genes than a normally is G's captured
captured them and provided a permanent
refuge for them in its own genome and it
releases these viral kinds and they
inhibit immune surveillance
I think climb up the glam up all the
receptors and prevent themselves from
seeing infected cells now the last major
topic not quite the less but almost the
last topic I don't want to talk about
today is MHC one presentation and it's
important because we figured out most of
how antigen is presented to the cell
surface by recognizing how viruses screw
the system up and it's a wonderfully
complicated system and it begins with
the synthesis of a molecule called MHC
one heavy chain and they gets
synthesized on the ribosome it uses the
sex 61 protein apparatus to get moved
into the ER and here it interacts with a
host chaperone called bit and another
protein called CNX and it forms this
complex this complex moves along the
wall of the ER and it gains another
protein called beta 2 microglobulin MHC
is always
scene with its partner beta-2
microglobulin and it gets another
protein called HC loses one gets one
gets another one CRT until finally it
moves to a region where which we call
the peptide loading complex the peptide
loading complex is primarily composed of
two proteins the taps may be three
so tap one and tap 2 antigen presenter
and tap hasten another small molecule
that sits inside the ER the taps span
the ER and they essentially form a pore
and the purpose of this pore is to
accept peptides that are released from
the 26s proteasome machinery so proteins
that are in the cell that are targeted
for degradation are the result of
ubiquitination or some other process get
loaded my tap in an atp-dependent
fashion and presented to the peptide
loading complex in the context of to pay
see what happens then is that these MHC
molecules move across until they find
any our exit site they lose everything
except the beta 2 microglobulin and the
MHC in the peptide and they get spit out
into cop 2 vesicles and get placed onto
the surface of cells sometimes the MHC
molecules gets put out without anything
when they get spit out without anything
they get degraded so they're targeted
for degradation if you don't have
peptide you're not taking the right
course you're not following the
prescribed exit pathway from the cell
and you pay for it virus proteins
interfere with MHC one mediated antigen
presentation and as you can see from
this there are a lot of targets a lot of
different ways in which a virus can
effectively shut the host down and let's
take a look at them so there's a little
tiny protein called
IC
47 it's 12 kilo daltons it's made by
herpes simplex virus and it sits right
here so it's the new Sentinel for
essentially effectively preventing
peptides from entering the antigen
presentation mechanism actually
physically blocks antigen presentation
and as a result of that I see P 47 which
remains attached to the ER effectively
prevents peptide presentation
I know virus e 19 does it another way
so the viral molecules are in the gray
and what it does is it blocks the
interaction of MHC 1 with the patient
and when that happens you exclude
peptide from loading in the complex and
it can't get in there and that MHC gets
shot out and it gets degraded nothing
gets presented on the cell surface h CMV
makes a protein called us6 human
cytomegalovirus and us6 actually sits
inside the ER and it has a luminal
surface one inside and a cytoplasmic
domain one outside and the cytoplasmic
domain binds ATP and it prevents ATP
binding to tap and that prevents peptide
loading and remember I told you this was
an atp-dependent process if you don't
generate energy you don't get the
peptide into the ER EBV makes a protein
called B NLF 2a and I certainly don't
want you to know that any more than the
others and that prevents peptide and ATP
binding to tap so it's acting just like
to the proteins that we discussed before
ICP 47 that prevents entry into tap and
us 6 which inhibits the ATP binding
activity so there's a very complex array
of these guys and here we have another
one human side a megalo virus makes
another protein us 3 and for some reason
cytomegalovirus
make lots of these proteins and we'll
get to that in just a second but this is
a glycoprotein
and it interacts with two payson and if
it's a glycoprotein you know that it's
stuck in the membrane here somewhere and
that results again in MHC one heavy
chain degradation so it gets released
from the beta 2 microglobulin it gets
shoved out into the cytoplasm
it's a wandering lost soul and it gets
eaten alive by the proteasome now
there's another small molecule called MK
3 and it's made by cytomegalovirus and
it again targets the peptide loading
complex and it targets it for
degradation by ubiquitination so it
spits out MHC and it interacts both with
tap and with tapassin so it's growing
this way and it shoves the MHC right out
into the Purdue yourself so that's how
you inhibit MHC 1 presentation and as
you can see there a variety of ways and
I haven't even discussed the fact that
viruses can also inhibit translation of
MHC and infected cells they can restrict
transcription of MHC so there isn't
really more than one way to skin this
cat in terms of exogenous antigen
presentation this is the role of MHC 2
MHC 2 is a protein that aggregates
doesn't aggregate it it interacts with
something called the invariant chain
inside of these vesicles and cells and
matures through the golgi apparatus
until it gets to a vehicle where the
invariant chain is degraded once the
invariant chain is degraded MHC 2 has
the capacity to bind peptide where does
the peptide come from well all those
cells that were releasing and were a
pitocin and releasing protein are the a
patata bodies and the proteins get
endocytosed these bodies activate the pH
gets lower proteins get protea lies and
now they become fodder for MH
to an MHC to binds peptide larger
proteins and takes them to the cell
surface in a very specific manner using
the very specific physicals and these
get presented and recognized by cd4
cells so I told you that
cytomegalovirus is just a wonderful
source for trying to understand how MHC
presentation actually works and it is
because it finds a way to attack every
single point within the MHC presentation
pathway there's a tengaman protein
remember what that is that's a little
space between the nucleocapsid on the
envelope that inhibits the proteosome
and does it by phosphorylating
different components us6 inhibits MHC 1
translocation to the endoplasmic
reticulum it can inhibit us 3 can
inhibit MHC transport across the
endoplasmic reticulum to other protein
is to and eleven fourths MHC one into
the cytoplasm again it's the lost sole
effect annual eighty is an MHC one
mimetic so it looks just like MHC one
that down regulates NK cells and CTL
cells by interacting with the inhibitory
receptors so to summarize everything I
know about MHC intersession we have to
think about the fact that viruses have
to cope with their hosts and for the
host to succeed viral antigens must be
presented on the cell surface for the
virus to succeed it must prevent that
event from occurring let me just finish
with one last story that just came out a
couple of months ago and it's an
interesting for a different reason these
are three hundred different ways in
which the immune system is modulated but
we've begun to talk about host micro
RNAs and how they have a role in virus
replication you heard about hepatitis C
and how it needs one well this is a
virus called herpes virus I marry that
immortalizes human T cells so it takes
normal T cells and it allows them to
grow forever and this virus expresses 7u
rich non-coding RNAs herpes same area
you rich rnase and two of these have
binding sites for three different host
micro RNAs and it turns out that in
these transform cells that in these
immortalized cells the abundance of a
very specific micro RNA Mir 27 is
dramatically reduced and it's a result
of Hsu or directed degradation so the
virus has found a way to attack a host
micro RNA that results or partially
results in this immortalized phenotype
so thank you and all the stuff will be
on the test on Wednesday